oh hi welcome back to game life
we begin this week with some
disappointing news irrational games has
announced that it will delay the launch
of bioshock infinite back from its
original date of october 16th
all the way to february 26th
2013.
the game's creative director ken levine
said that the team wants to add in some
new improvements to bioshock infinite to
make it quote something even more
extraordinary additionally levine said
irrational will not show bioshock
infinite at e3 or any other trade shows
this year
the interesting twist here is that when
wired interviewed ken levine in march he
was very enthusiastic about the october
release date saying we know when it's
time to put pencils down now the big
question is is irrational games really
adding extra features to bioshock
infinite or are there just unforeseen
issues with the development process we
won't know for sure until next year
and now for this week's big news
you might have already heard the word
gotcha before it's the japanese word
meaning those vending machines that are
so popular there where you can get toys
now it's been in the news recently in
japan for a slightly different context
mobile video games players in games that
use gotcha systems can spend money in
virtual vending machines in their cell
phone games hoping to get rare items if
they complete full sets of these items
they can get even more rare items this
has become big money for companies like
dna and gree but like similar
controversies over games like farmville
here in the united states it's not
without its downside parents in japan
have begun to report tales of kids
spending thousands of dollars via their
cell phones on games with gotcha systems
in response gree and dna said they would
limit kids spending but the japanese
government's consumer affairs agency
said earlier this month that the gotcha
sales might actually be illegal and
violate the country's gambling laws
the possibility of a government gotcha
crackdown actually caused stock in green
dna to drop by over 20 percent and
japan's mobile game companies responded
immediately by saying last week that
they would move to end all gotcha sales
that's it for this week's game life
we'll see you next time